this next in America are they more
healthier I'm gonna go no crispity
crunchity in a buttery that's like a
really good description a delicious
of course it's delicious should I might
keep they're gonna fall out I know I'd
be good at ice cream like I make flurry
with a lot of thing isn't it what
Twiggy's I've seen this in nearly every
single TV show slimey I've heard that
there's like no it like expiry date
which has to be good for you that's good
stuff that's not good oh very well I'm
by the foreigner' this is a reason why
the US has built a global Empire we are
proud that we have fought beside you in
every world war in Australia we don't
have this I've heard of cinnamon rolls
because of like US television and us
movies the Americans put cinnamon in
everything that's really good
it's very processed and sugary I heard
that you guys can get the cinnamon rolls
at like restaurants because I totally
order the cinnamon roll
I just suck why isn't the shape of a
baby bottle oh can I can I make a lot
maybe a baby showers I can see these
that they oh oh wow I was not expecting
that I thought it would be liquid this
is needlessly sexual it's very phallic
but delicious
that is absolutely do it wow that's
really really really sweet there's
nothing natural about this for her I
wouldn't even bother with the Red Bull I
just got one of these I'm pretty certain
we had these a while ago in Australia
but um like everything fun in Australia
we get AB and ingredients sugar okay so
you just I'm not gonna mix this with
like Pepsi or something oh no you point
your mouth I can see why they'd hurt
your penis if you put them on your penis
it's not going down I've swallowed and I
can feel it in my stomach that is one of
the most amazing things I hope that's it
that's diabetes starting from all the
notches even from your country I'm
having the biggest sugar high in my life
right now America thank you so much for
making me so excited
[Music]